so thank you peter festival for the kind
invitation a very generous introduction
um i'm really pleased to be here
preaching to the converted
it is so good to see so many young
people here many of you are under 50. um
good we're awake so uh it's a real
pleasure to be here to talk to you about
the west as peter said uh for those of
you who don't know me i co-host a
political
discussion show on youtube with my
friend and colleague francis foster in
which we tried to have honest
conversations about many of the issues
we'll be hearing about today
and in fact many of the guests that you
uh will see here today have been on on
the show uh and also the other thing
that many of you probably know about me
is i'm originally from russia
and my wife's ukrainian
yeah
so i've been sleeping on the sofa
for about eight years now uh we'll just
get this up because i wanted to quote
one of my uh former countrymen uh
alexander solzhenitsyn who i think many
of you will probably know
now before i uh talk about alexander
solzhenitsyn i want to make clear i'm
not in any way uh comparing myself to
him uh alexander sergeantson had a very
different life my parents sent me to uh
boarding school in england
he was in the soviet gulag where he had
to endure starvation diet brutal
punishment and a complete deprivation of
his liberty so at least we have that in
common um
so one of the things that alexander
solzhenitsyn talked about was
what makes a society successful what
makes a society function well he said
that if a nation's spiritual energies
have been exhausted it will not be saved
from collapse by the most perfect
government structure or by industrial
development
a tree with a rotten core cannot stand
it cannot stand if it has a rotten core
now the other thing i would say about
alexander sergeants and i think he did
make a bit of a mistake because once he
got out of the camps and went to the
west he got to america and he saw that
while western society was great
it was not perfect
and so he began to lecture
at various universities and he began to
lecture americans about their society
and telling them things that they did
not want to hear
i'm not going to make that mistake
that's why i've come to britain where
you love hearing how terrible you are
so i'm going to tell you about that
instead
i joke of course i'm not here to lecture
you i'm here for very different reasons
as peter mentioned this is a picture of
my wife and i only a few days ago
as you can see she's pregnant not me
because we're old school
[Applause]
[Applause]
so i'm not here to lecture you as a
foreign visitor about your country
i'm here for very personal reasons
for very important reasons
in a few weeks my wife will give birth
and we will have a child and if
everything goes well we may have another
child and if everything goes really well
they may have children too
and all of them will live here in the
west just like me
and i want us in our society and for
them to live in the prosperity and
safety that we all now enjoy that is why
i'm going to tell you some things
let's be honest that you all know
but also some of them you will not want
to hear so i apologize to you in advance
for both of those things now what is it
that i want to say does anybody know
what this is
very good sir it's a wooden plane made
out of wooden leaves
in world war ii in the pacific theater
of war mainly between the united states
and japan
they needed to control
the ocean and to do that you need naval
bases or you need some kind of places
where you can drop off supplies
and both the americans and the japanese
took over a bunch of small islands in
the pacific and they began to drop off
weapons ammunition medicine clothing on
these islands
and the deal they did with the native
tribes that lived there fairly
technologically primitive tribes is they
would share
the advances of western civilization
medicine clothing etc food tint food
with the natives and the quality of
their lives improved dramatically in a
very short period of time
and then the war ended
and the americans and the japanese
packed up and took all their medicine
and their clothes
and their supplies and left
and the quality of lives of the people
that lived there dropped massively
so what do you do
well think about it from the point of
view of the natives all they saw was
these
weird shapes come in and land on their
island and some soldiers who marched
around
and they thought
that the prosperity and the safety and
the medicine and the clothing that they
enjoyed
could be reproduced
how do you reproduce that well what you
do is you imitate you build planes out
of wood
you make wooden rifles and you march
around with them
you imitate the things that you've seen
because you think that is what produces
medicine and clothing and prosperity etc
right
now it's a strange thing but are we that
different
now in the west
we talk about all these things we talk
about capitalism democracy we talk about
freedom and free speech but are we
really committed to those or are we
imitating
take capitalism what does capitalism
mean right what capitalism means to if
you ask an economics professor they'll
tell you capitalism is about a society
in which there's a free exchange of
goods and services
right what does capitalism actually mean
to most of us
it means that you have the opportunity
to use your talents and your skills to
produce things that you share with other
people and if they are value to others
you will be rewarded for this
and we have the understanding that this
will be done in a relatively fair system
right do we have a relatively fair
system
a system in which multinational
corporations pay less tax than jimmy
carr
while young people
have to wait until they're 40 to buy a
house
is that capitalism
the way it was intended
we talk about democracy
at the last presidential election in
america
a major newspaper the oldest newspaper
in the united states published a story
about the son of one of the candidates
that was unflattering
and the same corporations that don't pay
any tax what did they do they prevented
that story from being shared
because it was quote unquote russian
disinformation
and we know for a fact
that if this had been a story about the
other candidates son
that would never have happened
is that democracy
and we know for a fact because the
research shows it that many of the
people who voted for his father
would not have voted for his father had
they known about the story and we now
know of course that the story is largely
true
right is that democracy are we just
imitating we talk about freedom but the
moment we get scared we're very happy to
give away our rights to the government
right and we talk about freedom of
speech and yet this country arrests
thousands of people
every year for things that they say on
social media
now mostly you'll be familiar with this
case
harry miller
who tweeted something a transphobic
limerick apparently on twitter and he
had the police call him up
and ask him to check his thinking
when we interviewed him on trigonometry
he said i've sent i said to this police
officer said you're a police officer and
he said yes and i said and you're
telling me you need to check my thinking
and he said yes he said do you have any
idea what that makes you
right
now
one of my great heroes a big lefty
comedian by the way george carlin he
said that political correctness is
fascism pretending to be manners
right i agree with that
how many of you know where political
correctness the term itself comes from
one man excellent comes from the soviet
union
1917 the russian revolution
and had nothing ever political
correctness had nothing ever to do
with politeness with preventing offence
with ensuring that people's feelings
were protected
political correctness had one purpose
and one purpose only to enforce the
party line of the day
so that people like my ancestors in the
soviet union would say something that
was true and they would be told well
comrade this is factually correct but
it's politically incorrect
why does it matter where it comes from
well i'll tell you why it matters
this is a man called george kennan
he was the soviet um the u.s ambassador
to the soviet union under harry truman
and
he's the man largely responsible for the
policy of containment of the soviet
union he influenced decades of american
strategic thinking and western thinking
about the soviet union having spent a
lot of time there and this is what he
said he said we must have the courage
and self-confidence to cling to our own
methods and conceptions of society after
all the greatest danger the greatest
danger is that we become like the thing
that we're trying to cope with
we become like our enemies
a bad word enemies isn't it
it's unpleasant we don't have enemies
anymore do we
do we because we're nice people
we like to trade
we like to have peace with others
we have no enemies we have live in this
globalized world right
and the best thing about it is everyone
everywhere in the world thinks exactly
like us right
right
now if i ask you that question you all
know what the answer is but deep down we
behave like that's true
is it true
is it true that we have no enemies is it
true that everyone everywhere in the
world thinks like us
i'm going to introduce you to some of my
russian friends i'm going to play a
video for you in a second if we could
don't play yet
before i do i want to tell you who the
people are that you're about to see so
some of them you will recognize in a
second vladimir putin is one of them uh
the president of belarus alexander
lukashenko is another and the other
people you see mainly from television
are two men in particular called
vladimir laviov
these are the sort of pierce morgan and
andrew neil of the russian media space
they host the two most popular tv shows
in russia
and i'll remind you
80
of the russian public get all of their
information from television exclusively
they are not on twitter
they're not on twitter they're not on
facebook they get the information from
this
[Music]
foreign
there you go
we have no enemies right
now am i telling you this because i want
to scare you
no
i don't think we have anything to be
scared of
uh just
if you don't know anything about russian
politics you only need to know one thing
this charming fella who's who's talking
about uh how europeans are cowards who
need to be conquered with a whip
he is the leader of the russian liberal
democrats
i should say former leader he uh passed
away in a very timely way a couple of
weeks ago his name is like his name was
vladimir nowski
so
am i telling you this to scare you
george cannon come back to this he said
the son
is impervious to the logic of reason
and highly sensitive to the logic of
force
right
but here's what he also said
said if you make it clear that you are
strong
you will not need to use force
if you're confident in who you are and
what you stand for you will never need
to have a showdown in which people's
egos get involved
and george cannon is the architect of
the cold war which prevented nuclear war
between
our two countries
and which prevented
the soviet union dominating the world
right
now you don't believe me do you
because i'm a you know my wife's
ukrainian
i'm biased on this right and george
kennan he's an evil american imperialist
right
that's what vladimir lenin said
stick your banner in
if it's soft
keep going
if you feel steel pull
back now is lenin relevant
to he was alive 100 years ago the
russian revolution was 100 years ago
has any of you been been to moscow
did you go to the mausoleum
where is the mausoleum
red square where's red square
in the heart of the capital of russia
here it is
what does that mean
his body lies there as a reminder to all
russians of our history
right hasn't been buried anywhere it's
in the heart of our capital what does
that mean well look at our country here
in the uk
winston churchill
in parliament square down the road from
here
why is he there is winston churchill
there because he was a great man who we
love and respect
sure
but he's not only there for that reason
is he
he's a symbol the statue is the symbol
of defiance in the face of tyranny
of courage in the face of bravery
right
a symbol
as is the act of defacing it
right
the people who did this did not do this
to insult
churchill
the people who did this did this because
they are demeaning the very things that
our country stands for
the very ideals that we hold to be
important
were defaced why is that do you think
the people who did this want britain to
be great
right so what's the answer
what is the answer do we fight
or show you the answer
we must have courage and self-confidence
to cling to our own methods and
conceptions of society
that's what cannon said don't have to
fight
we don't have to fight
all we have to do is remember who we are
now look
people on our side of the argument get
upset by these words and by the
discussion around them
right
i think that's a mistake
i think that's a mistake
because
i think these issues are important
i've experienced racism
when i was at school
someone told me to i quote go back to
russia you [ __ ]
it's hurtful i haven't spoken to that
teacher since
worst geography teacher ever
[Music]
you will never eradicate racism from the
human heart by doing this thing that we
now call
fighting racism
you will never eradicate racism from the
human heart by doing something called
anti-racism
but you can and should eradicate racism
from the human heart
by doing is called some something called
embracing the very western idea
that we're all born of equal worth
and of equal dignity
it's a western idea and a very unusual
one around the world
what about inequality
can you eradicate it by chastising
people for being successful
i don't know i don't think you can
but what you can do
is make people feel like the society in
which they live is fair
and if you do your best and you apply
yourself you will succeed and you will
be rewarded
right
in other words we have to get
the boundaries that are in place that
prevent people from succeeding on their
america
out of their way so people don't feel
like the main factor determining whether
you as a young person are going to have
a good life and have a place to settle
down in
and buy a property is how rich your
parents are
right
and whether they can give you a deposit
and finally identity
this division that we've seen in the
last six years
where we call each other snowflakes and
nazis and all of this other nonsense
that will never heal our society right
what if we embrace the very western idea
that you're not judged
by where you come from
or the color of your skin
or what's between your legs
or who you love
you're judged on your actions
and your thoughts
and your ideas
what if we did that
one final thing i'm not a religious man
but i can't help noticing
that every major religion particularly
the abrahamic ones and every major
spiritual practice and frankly every
happy person you've ever met
they have one thing in common
they all practice gratitude
they're all grateful for what they have
we are
the luckiest people in the history of
the world
and if we're grateful for that and if we
remember that
then our children and our grandchildren
may as well thank you very much
[Applause]